Nebraska might have just saved
themselves a couple million dollars in
the transfer portal because the number
two recruit in the country Dylan Rola
just changed his commitment from Georgia
to Nebraska Rola is the son of a
Nebraska Legend and he might end up
becoming the best QB Nebraska has had in
a while head coach Matt rule was looking
into grabbing an experienced quarterback
from the transfer portal but he said
that costs around $1 to $2 million just
to put that money into perspective 49ers
QB Brock pie who is a favorite to win
the MVP award is currently making
$870,000 this year don't think for a
second that Nebraska is getting off easy
in the money department now that a guy
like Rola is on their roster he's going
to be wanting all the nil deals so that
$1 to2 million they saved for the
transfer portal it'll probably find its
way in rola's Pockets but the investment
is going to be worth it considering how
Elite of a prospect he is